voilà c'est ce soir à minuit et demi
vous aurez de la chance puisque vous
pourrez suivre l'intégralité du match
entre le conte est champion qui était un
match très intéressant
nous allons maintenant à l'olympia
direction l'olympia des ondes direction
la loge de qui de julien clerc dont soir
julien bonsoir c'est pas tout à fait la
loge c'est le sait sur scène voilà c'est
sur la scène parce que donc vous
démarrez à l'olympia et où l'on
s'aperçoit brusquement que vous faites
et en même temps 25 ans de carrière on
n'arrive pas y croire si vous y tenez ça
fait c'est le plaisir d'être encore là
ouais alors pourquoi l'olympia parce que
finalement on vous a vu ces temps
derniers on ne vous a vu on s'est
habitué à vous voir sur des scènes
beaucoup plus grande il m'a fallu voyez
depuis la dernière fois que j'ai fait
l'olympia qui était parait-il
en 1974 il m'a fallu tout ce temps là
pour faire le tour des autres salles de
paris et maintenant j'y reviens
maintenant vous revenez une salle cru
petit oui je crois que les gens sont
contents de voir les artistes un peu
plus près à nouveau alors ce spectacle
est ce que ce sera essentiellement enfin
paris essentiellement mais il y aura
beaucoup des nouvelles chansons du
dernier album no 1 n'aura pas trop non
non un set peut-être
et puis vous savez je crois dans les
spectacles on aime bien entendre ce
qu'on ce qu'on connaît déjà ce qu'on a
aimé qui représente peut-être des
moments de votre vie et c'est pour ça
qu'il y aura beaucoup d'anciennes
chansons aussi et comme vous le disiez
tout à l'heure à 25 ans ça permet
d'avoir un répertoire suffisamment large
pour pouvoir faire voyager les gens dans
des ambiances musicales différentes
tout de suite on vous écoute en
répétition julien clerc
il faut un porte avions dans un extrait
de combien
et rendez vous
lambert actuel tout le
la peine a dit
ça
à
le temps
de là bas
au tampon
oh
ouah
ce
à part
oh
julie est clair en répétition gelli a
finalement c'est un spectacle qui va
devoir beaucoup à étienne roda-gil parce
qu'entre les nouvelles chansons vous
chantez même les anciennes j'imagine
vous reprenez des chansons de l'ue et
oui évidemment je reprends une chanson
détiennent mais il ya aussi des chansons
de david mcneil de genre du club de deux
fils du couple important pardon jean
loup dabadie françoise hardy maurice
vallet donc je crois que tout le monde
tous les gens avec qui j'ai eu la chance
de travailler pendant toutes ces années
ce sont représentés dans ce spectacle et
comme vous l'avez vu il ya donc je
pourrais dire presque deux spectacles en
a il y à une partie avec un orchestre
électrique rock puis qui rejoint un
moment donné par un grand orchestre que
vous venez de le voir là voilà où
j'interprète beaucoup de chansons
effectivement des années 70 dans leurs
arrangements originaux qui était écrit
par jean claude petit ou jean claude
vannier à l'époque alors là vous
m'amenez la transition sur un plateau
parce que je vais vous montrer quelques
images julien quelques images et vous
allez me dire en les regardant je vous
pose une question après regardez tout de
suite les nuages
on entend même
parfois les doigts
avec son équipage
il partit lentement
mais d'autres rivages chevauchant les
grands dauphins blancs vous en souvenez
la question est idiote parce qu'on a
laissé des marques et j'allais vous
demandez que en quelle année et et je
vous aurais dit que c'était tout début
de toute façon je chantais yann et les
dauphins quand j'étais en première
partie de gilbert bécaud à l'olympia
j'ai chanté quatre chansons à ce moment
là et je dois dire quand j'ai reposé
d'ailleurs le pied sur cette scène que
je n'avais pas vu depuis
depuis longtemps on retrouve assez vite
ses marques sur cette série faut dire
que j'ai beaucoup chanter et aussi elle
a cette salle a effectivement une magie
on est on est tout près des gens
effectivement j'avais un peu oublié ça
ça c'est bien de retrouver cinq
merci julien clerc on vous souhaite
plein de courage et puis après tout on
vous dit merde voilà votre autre chose